JONATHAN LEE: This
is the first panel
in the afternoon that
attempts to kind of examine
the practice of design, what's
kind of behind the scenes.
And we have some
wonderful guests here
that I'm very, very pleased
to join on stage with.
I'm going to do some
brief introductions.
And then I'm going to
let these guys speak
for themselves and for
some of the programs
that they are kind of
chairing or leading.
And we'll have some lively
discussion, hopefully.
Vivian, immediately next to me,
is an award-winning designer
and entrepreneur.
Currently, she is
the Chief Founder
in Residence at 30 Weeks.
It's Google's founder
program for designers.
Previously, she was
founder and CEO of Snaps
and co-founded the design
studio Tronic in New York City.
Scott Doorley is the
creative director
of the Stanford D
School, where he teaches
visual design and
communication design.
He's the co-author of
the book "Make Space."
And he designs spaces for people
looking to bring creativity
into their life and
their workplace.
He's a designer, teacher,
mentor, artist, and father.
And most importantly,
he loves ampersands.
Andre joins us from
General Assembly.
And he has spent the
last six years designing
learning experiences at
Apple, Obama for America,
and of course, GA.
For the past two
years, he's been
working to create the
User Design Experience
Immersive, a 10-week, full-time
program at General Assembly.
Enrique Allen is a general
partner and co-founder
at Designer Fund.
Previously, Enrique was
a designer at VC firms,
including 500 Startups,
Facebook Fund, and Venrock.
At those funds, he helped invest
in companies like Wildfire,
which was acquired by Google,
and Behance, which a lot of you
probably know, which
was acquired by Adobe.
He's also a Stanford
alum and is teaching
D Media at the Stanford
School of Design
and has been teaching that
for the past five years.
And finally, on
the end, Michael is
the founding partner
and creative director
of 2X4 in New York City, a
National Design Award winning
firm.
He has three decades of design
education experience teaching
at the Rhode Island
School of Design,
teaching at Yale School
of Art, and is currently
the Director of the
Graphic Architecture
Project at Columbia's graduate
program for Architecture.
His new book
"Multiple Signatures"
was published by
Rizzoli last year.
And with that, I'm going to
advance to some of your slides.
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL:
Hello, everyone.
I'm Vivian Rosenthal, Founder
in Residence of 30 Weeks.
30 Weeks is a program
aimed at design founders
with an education bent,
sort of an incubator
meets education model.
It's 30 weeks long,
as the name implies.
It's in New York City.
And to date, it's been
fairly under the radar,
as we've just launched
this September.
The image behind me is a shot
of our space down at 250 Hudson.
So this is led by
Google but also has
a number of incredible design
schools partnered with us,
including Hyper Islands and
Cooper Union, SVA, Parsons,
and Pratt.
And what we're
really looking to do
is to help people with a
design background become design
founders, by bringing together
design business and technology.
So it's very much about
a collaborative process.
And we're really looking
to get the word out.
So obviously, this is an
audience of designers.
So please come find me
afterwards or find me
on Twitter, if you're
interested in learning more,
because we're hoping to change
the way that education happens,
by giving people a chance to
move into what we call learning
through launching,
which is really
the mantra of the program.
JONATHAN LEE: I had
asked each panelist
to supply an image
of their program,
as well as an historical
or personal image to kind
of kick start the conversation.
So this is Vivian's.
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL: Yes.
So when I was asked to
give a historical image,
I was very influenced
by the Bauhaus.
I used to be an architect.
That's what I studied.
And the Bauhaus,
if you translate it
literally from
German to English,
it's the school of building.
And so I think today what
we're doing with 30 Weeks,
as part of this
new incubator, is
thinking about a
school of building.
But of course, now
what we're building
is often intangible and digital.
But nonetheless, it's building.
I think there's been a shift
in what building means,
but it's interdisciplinary
practiced.
And so this is something
that I studied in school
and really excited me, to see
all these different arts coming
together.
And for the same reason,
I'm excited about where
we are collectively today.
JONATHAN LEE:
Moving on to Scott.
SCOTT DOORLEY:
I'm Scott Doorley.
I'm the Creative Director
of the Stanford D School.
The D School is a little
bit of a misnomer.
We're not a school.
That would be like the
School of Engineering
or the School of
Education or the Graduate
School of Business.
And we teach design, but
we teach design mostly
to non-designers.
So we take people who are
coming to the university
as graduate students mainly,
looking at getting a business
degree or an education degree
or an engineering degree.
And then we give them a process
to approach problem solving.
So we have a lot of people
who are starting businesses.
And they're starting businesses
with the design bent.
Or we have people who
are creating curriculum.
And we help them create
a curriculum design bent.
And for us, that means
they're human-centered.
They're highly intentional.
And they prototype
their way to an answer.
Within that though,
we do teach a lot
of design-oriented classes.
I teach few, one
with the Enrique,
D Media, which is about
designing across platforms also
another one called Storytelling
Visual Communication Studio
that's about thinking
about how you communicate.
This example I gave-- we've been
playing around with getting out
of the classroom,
because what we found
was we give projects
to students.
Everything's project-based.
So a lot of the
learning is actually not
happening when we're with them.
We're with them for three
to four hours a week.
But there are all these
gaps where they're actually
doing a ton of learning,
and we're not there.
So we thought, how can we
get in touch with them.
We created this
thing called Minnow,
which serves like a home
brew little web app that
allows us to send super-short
videos under a minute to closed
groups.
And the way we're using
it is for students teams
to reflect on what
they're doing or to send
tips, when we know they're
about to go into something
that might be taxing for them.
Like they're about to go into
user testing, and we know that.
And we can send them something
to just give them a little hit.
And the thing we found
when we started testing it,
which was simultaneously
discouraging and exciting,
was that a lot of the
students came back.
We gave them, as our first
test, four one-minute videos
over a weekend when they were
going to do some prototyping.
And the students came back and
said, I learned more in those
four minutes that I had
in four weeks of class,
which on the one hand,
you're like, that's great.
Wow, we taught you
in four minutes.
And on the other hand,
you're like, what
happened in the
rest of the class.
But as it as it turns out, I
think that's not totally true.
I think that was the
perception that they had.
They felt like they
had learned more,
just because the timing of
the content was so good.
To be totally honest,
I shot the videos,
and they were kind of crap.
They were not great videos.
But the timing was something.
And so we're
looking really start
to look at when are
we giving students
content as a big question
that we're asking.
And then I just
want you to absorb
this photo for one second.
This is Charles Eames house.
And there are a bunch of
nuns sitting on the floor,
and there's a noose in
the middle of the room.
And I was looking for
an image like this
because I wanted to
share somebody who's
a hero of mine, who's a nun
named Carita Kent, who taught
at the College of the
Immaculate Heart in LA.
She taught Art and Design there.
And she was like one of
these visionary people who
brought in the community
around her, to really teach
the students that were
there, many of whom
were studying to
be nuns, which is
why you have so
many nuns in here.
I should explain the noose.
But I'm going to hold on for
a second before I do that.
But she had this way
of really bringing
in people from the community.
So she had brought
in Charles Eames.
She brought in Alfred Hitchcock.
She brought it
Buckminster Fuller
to teach very small
groups of nuns.
And it was just kind
of amazing that she
was able to draw that energy in.
And the second thing is, she
was the queen of the assignment,
creating an assignment
that really pushes students
to explore what
they're thinking about
and how they're
doing their own work.
And she used a lot of
numbers in her assignments.
She would say, you have
to do 100 of these.
You have to do 50 of these
and then take 20 of those
and do 20 more and then take 10
of those and do 10 more those.
And it just reminded
me that there's
something about being able to
be in an educational environment
that gives you freedom
that you don't have.
So the noose is--
Charles Eames set up
a noose in the middle of his
room with a stack of boxes,
so that his kids could fly
into the boxes, which I thought
takes this kind of
frightening object
and makes it kind of delightful.
Thanks.
JONATHAN LEE: Thanks.
ANDRE PLAUT: Cool.
Hi, everyone.
My name as Andre Plaut.
I'm a Product Lead at
General Assembly working
on all of our
full-time programs.
And the idea behind
General Assembly
is to really help folks from all
sorts of different backgrounds
enter the world and kind
of transition their career,
be it anywhere from
marketing to an architect
into the world of
web development
or UX design or
product management.
And so for last two years,
I've been really building out
our 10-week, full-time
UX Design program
with a number of amazing
designers all around the world.
And this picture really
shows-- to something
that Scott was talking about--
the importance and the emphasis
that we put when we designed
our program in actual creation
and doing.
And something that was
really important to us
when we were
building our program
was that our students didn't
spend a whole lot of time
in the classroom, that there's
only so much so you can really
learn by listening to someone.
You will never really reach
this capacity as a designer,
if you don't actually
create and talk to people.
So we have a huge
emphasis on our students
to just get out of the
classroom, go into a park,
talk to people, watch
how they use technology,
really try to understand
what their needs
and how they just behave.
And that's ultimately
how we think
you'll become a great designer.
And again, our goal is to really
sort of spark that interest.
So the greatest
compliment we've ever
gotten from one of our students
is, that through this program,
they were sort of able
to find the thing that
got them excited to
wake up in the morning.
And so yeah, that's the program.
In terms of my
inspiration, I feel
like I went sort of totally
to a different place.
But the way that I look about
building learning experiences
is the way that you
should be building
any type of experience, be it
an app or a service or something
that I really draw
inspiration from and love,
which is music and
Bonnaroo, which
are what these images are.
So when we were actually
building this UX program
and the way that I've
tried to approach things
I've done with
the Obama campaign
and Apple is to really
think through what
are the type of experiences
that not only help
people learn something.
But what are the
types of experiences
that motivate people, that
sort of elevate them to become
something different
or something better?
What kind of experience
helps people come together,
sort of in a uniting purpose?
And I think those kind of
experiences are all around us.
And so this is just one thing
that kind of inspires me
on a day to day basis, so not
specific to design education,
but just an incredible
experience generally.
ENRIQUE ALLEN: Cool.
Hey, everybody, so
excited to see you.
There are all these
laptops out there.
Are you guys googling
stuff right now?
What are you doing?
Just checking that
you guys are awake.
As Jonathan mentioned,
my name is Enrique Allen.
I co-founded Designer
Fund with the mission
to help designers
create businesses
with meaningful
impact in the world,
hopefully in spaces that really
need design help from you guys,
like in education, health,
energy, and environment.
And one way that we
achieve our mission
is by investing in designers
who are starting new companies.
Another way that we do that
is through our professional
development program, Bridge,
which you see pictured here.
And Bridge really just
connects experienced designers
like yourselves
with top companies
here in the area
and our community.
And really, what
we're interested in is
helping accelerate the career
of really the best designers
and exposing them
to what it takes
to be great individual
contributors, great managers,
potentially design
directors, and maybe even
founders one day.
So that's what we're really
interested, in terms of Bridge.
And for my inspirational
historical design reference,
how many of you guys
know who this guy is?
Crickets maybe-- all right,
this is a John Dewey,
who was a really world-renowned
education reformer who's
quite prolific in his
writing and published
a number of books, including
"Democracy in Education,"
I believe, in 1916.
And he was also a huge
proponent of hands-on learning
as well as experiential
education and learning.
And one of the frameworks
that Dewey inspired
was this really, super
simple, basic feedback
loop, which is activity.
So we spend most of our
time doing activity;
reflection, how we
synthesize our experience;
and theory, how we
conceptualize that
into some framework
or some abstraction.
So there's some basic loop of
Activity Reflection Theory.
And when I started to reflect on
the designers that we work with
at Bridge, my own experience,
we spend most of our day--
let's say, at least
50%-- doing activity,
working on our
products and services.
Maybe we spend the other
40% with our family,
our personal time.
So that leaves maybe 10%
time for continued education.
So how should we structure
that remaining time?
And one of the
ah-ha moments I had,
inspired by John Dewey
and Scott Doorley,
is I think that we
might not actually
make enough time for
reflection in our process.
And arguably, we don't
need anymore theory.
We already have a
ton of activity.
We might be really
lacking in the reflection
part of that cycle.
And so that's
something that we've
been considering and
changing in our curriculum.
Thanks.
MICHAEL ROCK: I'm Michael Rock.
And I represent the rear guard
for this committee, I think.
I have two images that are
actually related and informally
related and also
conceptually related.
And this one is
from the Yale School
of Art, a final critique.
And the second one is
one from about 1926, also
a kind of final critique.
I teach simultaneously at
Yale in the School of Art
and at Columbia in the
School of Architecture.
And there's this
interesting overlap
between these two
different ways of thinking
about making in general.
But I think the thing
that's common in all design
experiences,
educational experiences,
is that it's a
combination of immersion
and this close looking
and that being together
and looking at
things really closely
in a very comparative way.
And so I love this
image form Yale,
because there's just so
much visual material.
And it's a complete
immersive environment.
But if you go to the
next one, this is 1926.
It's Kazimir Malevich at
the Unive Assen, which
was one of the revolutionary
schools of design
that came after the
1919 Revolution.
And what I like about
this is, that again,
it's a kind of
immersive environment.
It's a group of people,
both teachers and students,
looking together and
looking really closely.
But I think what was really
interesting about this period--
because this school
basically came out
of the Vkhutemas,
which is really
the precursor to what
the Bauhaus became,
and this idea of really trying
to create a revolution in form,
as well as a
political revolution
and trying to rethink the world
new, through the aesthetic
and trying to create an
image of a new world.
And what I find especially
interesting about that
is that when we Lenin
visited the school,
he was getting
old at that point,
and ultimately
declared the work they
were doing contrarevolutionary,
because it was in inaccessible.
It was elitist kind
of work, because it
was the work of a kind
of an aesthetic elite.
And so while they're
trying to enact,
in one way, aesthetic reform
or an aesthetic movement,
somehow they become
distanced from the political.
And I think this
kind of connection
between the aesthetic
and the political
is really something
we grapple with still.
JONATHAN LEE: Great.
Well, thank you all for
sharing your programs.
And I wanted to
start our discussion
to kind of ask you to share the
audience what your students,
or whatever you might
call them-- actually,
I'd loved actually know
what you call your students.
If they're not students,
what's the actual nomenclature
you use for that?
But what is the kind of
composition and the makeup
of them, as they apply, or
they come to your program?
What are you looking for?
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL: I'll start.
So we specifically don't call
them students at 30 Weeks.
We call them designers.
And that was a very
conscious decision,
for them to think of
themselves as not-- we
felt like students was a
little bit more passive.
And we want them to be
really taking an active role.
So that was sort of
critical in the makeup.
But yes, if you
want to just talk--
SCOTT DOORLEY: Yes.
We're at a large university,
so they are called students.
But we do play a
lot with language.
And I think it is
really important
to put them in a posture.
And our students
are actually not
Design students,
most of the time.
We have, I'd say,
10% Design students.
And ours are coming in from
all different directions.
ANDRE PLAUT: We do call our
students students as well.
And we were just talking about
this a little bit backstage,
this sort of interesting thing
where all of our students
are adults.
They're not necessarily--
they're certainly not kids.
And most of them have
graduated and have Masters.
And I think it's a really
fragile and vulnerable place
to be in a learning environment,
once you've already started
your career, or you're sort of
trying to perfect something.
And so I certainly
don't think there's
anything negative about
the term students,
but that you acknowledge
that we are all students.
It's about kind of elevating
that term, I think, as opposed
to the thinking of it more
from the lunch box and desk
kind of mentality.
ENRIQUE ALLEN: Yes,
likewise for us.
We don't call the designers
that we work with students.
I would assume many of you
maybe aren't interested
in going back to Design grad
school or something like that.
So we're interested in learning
from each other as a community,
as a network and sharing those
best practices that are rarely
shared publicly, but
doing that and more
of a peer-to-peer style.
MICHAEL ROCK: Yes, I
think it's similar.
I taught in Holland for a while,
at the Jan Van Eycke Academie.
And there, they very decidedly
excised the word student
from the vocabulary.
And everyone was referred to as
a participant, which I though
was an interesting
approach, but in a way,
somehow breaks down
the idea that there
is something to learn.
And there are people
who are teaching
and people who are receiving.
And I think that
whatever that term is,
we still believe at least that
there's something to impart,
that there's
knowledge to impart.
And that relationship between
teacher and student is intact.
JONATHAN LEE: And so
what are your students
or and designers
and non-designers
in Scott's case, what are they
kind of coming to you for?
Or what is it that
they're trying
to participate in and learn
from in your programs?
What are the core
issues that you're
seeing in today's context?
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL: Sure.
So one of the things
that we recognized
is that designers are
often seen as sort
of this work for hire person.
And so with 30 Weeks, we're
really trying to break that,
and not that there
isn't a role for that.
Obviously, there is.
But in our case, almost
everyone who applied up to date
had sort of been paid for
their services as a designer.
And we were really trying
to implement a shift
into the role of
being a founder.
And that doesn't mean you have
to start your own company.
It might be sort of being
a leader within an existing
company and really
pioneering change that way.
But it was really
a shift in mindset
and looking for the people
that had that grit and tenacity
and also a real desire to
make change in the world,
rather than just solving
for a specific brief
and then moving on to the next
brief and so on and so forth.
So we wanted people
to pick their heads up
and look at the world
around them and say,
what are the opportunities
here for change.
JONATHAN LEE: Those are
all preexisting designers?
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL: Yes,
in that case of 30 Weeks,
people are all designers,
from product design,
architecture, interactive
design, graphic design.
Really, it runs the gamut.
JONATHAN LEE: I'm going to
hop around a little bit,
because I'd like to stop
going across the row.
This isn't a classroom,
by any means.
Andre, can you speak a little
bit about your audience?
ANDRE PLAUT: Absolutely.
I think what's interesting
is that the folks that
come into GA are really
at the very beginning
of their careers.
So they aren't designers
when they come in.
They, again, might come
from a world of marketing
or engineering or literally
pretty much anywhere.
And they're coming
into our program
to transition and their careers.
So it's really to enter
the world as UX designers.
And so really, the
point of the program
is to, A, sort of help them
fall in love with this industry
and the craft and give
them just enough skill.
And the way we look at
it is, really, you're
going to learn how to do
this throughout your life
and throughout your career.
And that 10 weeks certainly
can't replace years and years
of experience, but
that it's supposed
to be this initial spark
that allows you to then go on
to a lifelong
learning experience.
And places like 30
Weeks and Designer Fund
are perfect places
for our students
to go to, once they have had
those experiences of working
somewhere and developing their
skills, which is sort of cool.
They can work together
in that sense.
JONATHAN LEE: Its kind of
like minimum viable skills.
It's a ship.
And how about at D School?
SCOTT DOORLEY: Yeah,
I was going to say,
there's actually--
I mention that there
are a lot of non-designers.
And that's given, I think,
me a particularly interesting
vantage point on what
design education is doing.
And we are trying to
give them challenges
that push their
creative thinking.
And we give them these
challenges, and they go out.
And they do them.
And immediately, whatever
challenge they're working on,
the design education gets
sucked into that challenge.
I'll give an example.
So we have students
working on K-12 schools.
And what we're thinking the
assignment that we're giving
them is that they're
going to go and use
design process to figure out
how to change-- I don't know--
whether it be curriculum
or the community
or the space of the school.
And then what happens is,
the teachers in the school
want the design
curriculum for themselves.
Or they go into a business.
And they're like looking at
how do people work together.
And how do we redesigned
collaboration space
at an office?
And then the people
in the business
want the design curriculum.
And so I think what I'm
seeing is, at this moment
right now, design,
everybody wants it.
And I think it's a
growth moment for design,
whether it be for
non-designers or people
who are trying to move
into design or people who
are long-term designers.
There's just this hunger for it.
And I think there's something
about the approach of design
at this moment that's really
useful, both in terms of it
working and in terms
of education that
has to do with being able to
engage the world to figure out
your problem, which is
just a useful thing when
the world feels really dynamic
versus thinking about as, I'm
going to learn a bunch of stuff.
And then I'll know something.
And then I'll be able to go
out and conquer the world.
I'm going to learn how
to find the knowledge I
need at any given moment.
To me, that's what design
is about and then use
that knowledge to bring
something into reality.
So in a sense, our
students are designers,
because they want
to use a tactic
to create something
in the world.
JONATHAN LEE: So
are they designers,
or are they using
design process?
SCOTT DOORLEY: I
mean, it's tricky.
I go back and
forth between that.
Sometimes I want to say,
they're not designers,
but they do design.
They're not a professional,
And then other times, if
I call them designers,
it makes them feel good.
And they do better work.
So I call them designers.
You know what I mean?
And I think it's
valid either way.
But it is different
than, say, trying
to become where your
practices is only design.
I'm working with people, so that
I can serve a design function
in whatever is
happening versus--
I'm going to do
what I do, and I'm
going to approach it from
a design perspective.
They're definitely
different, but I
like to play with
what we call them.
JONATHAN LEE: And Michael
how is that affecting
the universities?
MICHAEL ROCK: Well, I
think it's interesting,
because I think that-- it's
very hard to generalize
because there are so
many multiple ways
that people decide
to go to school.
But I think you could, in
the most general terms,
say that half the students
are escaping something.
The other half are trying
to get into something.
So half are basically
in a career,
and they're not necessarily
happy with where it is
or what they're doing.
And so they use
school as a lever
to escape from that situation.
And so it allows them to
reinvent themselves in a way
and rethink themselves
into some kind of new form.
And I think the other
half are basically
trying to enhance what they have
and professionalize in a way
that they couldn't do
professionally in the industry.
So some people, I
think, are really
trying to have this
life-changing experience.
And then that's probably
a little bit different
when you go to a two-year
graduate program,
where you're
getting yourself out
of your life and
starting something else,
rather than doing some kind
of professional development.
But I do think there's
this aspect which
is to deprofessionalize.
It's a really big desire
for a lot of students I see.
JONATHAN LEE: And how would
you define where we're headed?
It sounds like you
all how educate
people on design processes
and design thinking.
And if you call it a designer
or you call it something else,
that's up for debate.
But where we going?
And how should we
continue this growth?
Does it need this full spectrum?
Do you anticipate
everyone creating programs
that service all the different
phases of arc as a designer?
Or is it that you--
where should we go next?
ANDRE PLAUT: I think
there's something
that Scott said that I
completely agree with.
It's that there's
a sort of moment
that we're in right
now with design, where
a lot more people are
becoming aware of it.
And a lot more people
are understanding
how we can improve
things, regardless if it's
health care or politics
or how you get a cab.
And I think what's interesting
about design education is
that, first of all, everyone
in this room, you guys
have a set of skills and methods
and practices that don't just
solve the problem that you're
immediately working on.
They solve almost every problem.
And so I think the way that we
talk about design and the way
that we've individually
approach it
and how we mentor people
in our organization
and how we bring it
to our everyday lives
is sort of where I
think it needs to go.
In terms of design education
as a more formal kind of idea,
I think it is about bringing
the process and design
thinking and these
practices to other areas
and seeing where it
can be impactful.
ENRIQUE ALLEN: Yeah, I think
that the future of design
education will require a lot
more collaboration and a lot
more coordination amongst
organizations and institutions.
So schools-- and 30 Weeks
is a great example of that,
partnering with a number of
universities in New York.
I think we can do a lot better,
in terms of industry informing
curriculum at our
top schools here,
at TCA, at Berkeley,
at Stanford, et cetera.
And then once someone actually
leaves the institution,
then what-- whether it's GA,
or whether it's online courses,
or whether it's
continued education,
professional development
at that company.
So I think it's going to take
coordination and collaboration
across multiple phases of
a designers life cycle.
And I think one thing that we
really don't understand well,
at least in our research
is, what really sets apart
a top designer from
a junior designer.
What really sets apart
senior versus junior?
And what are these nuances that
are missing in the curriculum?
JONATHAN LEE: Yeah, I
want to know a little more
about any of your thoughts on
what makes a great designer.
And how many great
designers are your programs
shipping essentially?
Are we just making designers
that are mediocre ?
Or is this the formula for
making badass designers?
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL:
I know at 30 Weeks,
we're sort of shifting the
definition of even what
a designer is a little
bit away from aesthetics
and more towards
human-centered problem
solving and thinking
about how do you
create value in the world.
And in our view, a designer
is someone, hopefully,
who has empathy and can see
a problem and the solution
from many different
perspectives and can
try to help solve for
that, rather than just look
at things through
an aesthetic lens,
not that that's not important.
So we're taking a bit
more of a holistic view
of what a designer
is or what we'd
like a designer to include.
JONATHAN LEE: I guess I'm trying
to get at-- your program's
focuses are on various aspects.
But I'm wondering.
Are we neglecting
the other skills?
Do we think that
our designers are
being less good at color theory?
And they're kind of sucking
at typography even more.
And what should a
modern designer be?
MICHAEL ROCK: Well
maybe it is that design
has become such
complex practice,
that you can't
really say there's
one core skill you have to have.
So in a way, all
of these programs
represent the fact
that you need lots
of different kinds
of education for lots
of different kinds of things.
And one of the things
I always think about
is that the people in
class now are basically
finishing their career in 2060.
So what do they need in 2060?
We have no idea yet.
So we presume
they're going to need
new skills as they go along.
But on the other hand,
you like to believe
that there's certain things you
learn in school that you carry
with you your whole life,
that are part of you
and that you keep going back to.
There's a well there that
you can keep going back to,
and it doesn't run dry.
So I think that there has
to be some combination
of some core things
and some things
which get added
on in the future.
And I think that's what all
these programs are doing.
I think they're kind of creating
these prosthetic devices
to help us through or something.
It's kind of like design your
own Design education approach.
SCOTT DOORLEY: And I also think
what Michael is getting to is,
there are different
facets of it.
I do you think its
expanding so much
that the definition of a
designer is totally changing.
And people who are calling
themselves designers
now may not have felt
comfortable calling themselves
designers 20 years ago.
And that's great, because it
means that more people are
trying to be responding
to human needs.
And it means that
more people care
about how something
communicates through form.
It means that more people
are being experimental
in the way they develop things.
So it's great.
It's killer.
And then, at the same
time, I think design
as a practice, a
professional practice,
is getting more
and more nuanced.
It's just deepening and
deepening and deepening.
And it really needs to.
And there need to be
people who are going down,
down, down to the depths.
But they don't necessarily
have to be the same people.
And we're going to call
them the same thing.
We're going to call them a
designer maybe for a while.
But maybe they're
really different things,
and that's OK too.
But I think the
word kind of brings
with it-- in fact,
as I was totally
stalking Michael's
site this morning.
And he's got these three-word
design manifestos on there
that are just amazing.
They're great.
I don't know anything
about the project.
But they're really cool because
they're all really different.
And yet, they're all design.
They're all design.
You read them, and you're like,
yeah, that's what design is.
But none of them are the same.
They're fundamentally different,
and I think that's OK.
JONATHAN LEE: And
I think maybe it
relates to what Enrique was
saying too about collaboration.
Because I think that
probably increasingly
we're going to have to
cobble together these skills
to do things, where
everyone doesn't have
to be great colorists,
for instance.
But you need to know a great
colorist at some point,
to solve something
or to do something.
So the problems are probably
big enough and complex enough,
to where collaborative teams
of lots of different skills
come together.
And that's where, again,
you can educate people
in lots of different ways.
ENRIQUE ALLEN: We
definitely think
about how we can just
learn from the best
people in the business, so
bring together awesome designers
at Dropbox, at Pinterest,
at various companies,
to break down our
creative process,
look at the tools they're using,
the iteration cycles, what
date we're getting back.
So I think the more that
we share that information
as a community, we
can raise the bar
and continue to
keep that bar high.
So we think a lot about, again,
that peer to peer and role
models that we can
learn from each other.
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL: I
think just the one thing
I'd add-- in terms
of collaboration,
if we look at the
tech start-up scene,
the typical founders tend
to be engineers or someone
with an MBA or
business background.
And so one of the other things
we're looking at 30 Weeks
is how do we elevate designers
to think of themselves
as that triumvirate of they're
the third and missing link.
And if you bring together
those three types of people,
you have a really strong base.
And so that was something
that we're really
keen onto is collaboration
and making sure designers
are part of that practice.
ANDRE PLAUT: It's
such a powerful--
it's crazy to think that there
are so many things in the world
that we use and are so integral
to our lives that haven't been
designed or have been
designed by default.
And yeah, the work of 30
Weeks and just so much
of what we're all doing
is about putting designers
into that conversation
and at least introducing
more people who can
ask the right questions
and go through
the right process,
regardless of where they are.
JONATHAN LEE: Cool.
Well, I think I'm
going to wrap it up.
I'd like each of
you to tell me where
you hope your program
will be in the future.
I know that,
Michael, you brought
that it's a hard
thing to speculate on.
But where do you aspire toward?
SCOTT DOORLEY: I can
throw it out there.
I kind of began with
the thing talking sort
of leaking out of the
classroom a little bit.
And I think we did
a project recently
called Stanford
2025, which is funded
by the School of Engineering,
to look at what's the on campus
experience for students
in the year 2025,
in the age of online education.
This is Google.
YouTube is probably one
of the best learning
platforms in the
world, for real.
And that's happening.
And that's just one.
That's just one example.
So how do we let people come
into a safe place, where
they can misunderstand things
and explore, but then give them
something when they get beyond
it that keeps them connected
and keeps what Enrique
was talking about,
keeps them reflecting
on what they're doing
and not just getting
into the grind
and delivering,
delivering, delivering.
But what did I just do?
How did I deliver that so
well and that not so well?
And that ability
to reflect and stay
connected to a learning
community, whose agenda is
learning and expanding
and growing, I think
would be something
I'd like to see.
ANDRE PLAUT: Yeah.
I think, for our program at GA,
it's about a couple of things.
The first, I would
say, is just trying
to open up access to
more and more people.
And this is something
we're consciously
always trying to do.
It's how do we make
it more accessible,
especially to
folks that are just
completely underrepresented
in this field?
So we have this thing called
Opportunity Fund, where
we essentially just massively
reduce the cost of the program.
And that's a huge goal for us.
And the other one, because
we're so at the bottom of that
funnel in terms of-- or rather
at the top of the funnel, where
we're getting a lot of folks
who haven't heard about design
and who might be interested
in becoming a designer, kind
of evangelizing the
field as a whole in
and going out to
people who maybe
are really into product and
maybe who have opinions on it.
But they don't understand what
it took to create something.
Or they just have
no idea how to go
about making something
of their own, so really
evangelizing design as an
industry and as a practice
and as a mindset and
helping people come into it.
ENRIQUE ALLEN: I think
it's pretty simple for us.
Fast forward 10 years from now.
If we look back,
have we played a role
in helping start great
companies, like Airbnb,
et cetera?
If we look back
all the designers
that have participated
in Bridge are they
amazing individual contributors,
managers, directors,
even founders?
And then I think
the bonus for us
is if we can look back and say
that we've contributed to some
of this fundamental
infrastructure
that I think is needed
for designers to continue
to succeed to through tech.
MICHAEL ROCK: I
think [INAUDIBLE] we
have this interesting
condition where only about 30%
of people who study
architecture practice it.
And so I would
say, that in a way,
I would hope that we'd
even get to a smaller
percentage of that,
because I think
that the study of
architecture as a kind
of intellectual activity is an
incredible foundation for doing
lots of different
kinds of things.
And making buildings
or making cities
is only one sliver
of those things.
And I think that
increasingly, we
see the school as a school
of architectural thinking
and a way of thinking
about the diagram
or thinking about design, that
has multiple applications.
And I think that
in the future maybe
you have 10% who are
actually building buildings.
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL: Yeah.
And then just to sort
of follow on that.
For us, it's sort of taking that
kind of thinking and curiosity
and passion and
then bringing that
into creating a
product or a business
or service and sort
of fueling that.
And so we would obviously hope
that some of the designers
go on to start
companies or become
great leaders at
other companies.
And we're also looking to
scale the program, either
with other geographies
or larger class
sizes, so a lot
of the same goals.
JONATHAN LEE: Well,
thank you guys
for sharing some your
thoughts on where
modern design is,
design education.
And I think we've burned
through a lot of our Q&A time,
so I'm going to
release us at that.
So thank you guys very much.
[APPLAUSE]